tens was supposed to be the next great
cs go prodigy
he was young explosive and boasted some
of the nastiest aim the game had
ever seen
but as soon as he got his first big
break he did the one thing
no prodigy can ever afford to do he
choked
hard hoping to expect more of and
actually we're expecting more we're not
hoping to we do expect more out of him
and then out of nowhere just as people
were beginning to write him off
ten's got another chance to fulfill his
destiny
ascends he becomes a super saiyan blue
like he goes
higher than what's expected of him
because the man just pops off
[Music]
one enemy remaining but you gotta keep
your eyes on tens any time he has this
jet all
up he is able to do damage there's the
first gets the instant reload down goes
the second and
finds the third and a pumbaa tent's
gonna wrap the corner spike is down he's
got this thing locked down he's gonna
fly it
oh my god tens he just dominated
one
wow
30 seconds left so
oh my god dead
holy smokes these days tens is the god
of valorant rifling
but before that he was a scrappy
up-and-coming 15 year old trying to make
a name for himself in the world of
competitive cs go
eat lunch now please okay big bowl of
soup
victory soup what set him apart wasn't
that he just looked promising
this kid was a wonder child he looked
like he was born to play cs go for
starters he boasted
incredible game sets with the ability to
destroy his opponents in some truly
incomprehensible ways
content dude but the thing that truly
stood out about tens was his
aim he spent every waking second
fine-tuning his truly unbelievable
flicks
from aimbots to osu to
doing both at once this is probably the
worst idea i've ever had in my entire
life
there was pretty much no aim trainer
that tens hadn't spent countless hours
grinding and i'll just like
get on this ledge and just practice
killing 100 bots
and seeing how fast of a time i can get
and as soon as he hopped on a
matchmaking server
the results of his training were obvious
ah four four four
whoa
the question of course was whether tens
would be able to replicate that
performance on an official server
after climbing the ranks of ecs's north
american development league ten spent
the better part of two years trying to
distinguish himself on orgs like
neventik
blackout and resolute before being
offered a chance to sign with dignitas
midway through 2018.
unfortunately that didn't go very well
and hence spent the next year hopping
from stack to stack as he watched his
clips take the cs go subreddit by storm
there was no denying it
tens was an animal and at some point
someone had to take a chance on him so
his incredible mechanics could shine on
csgo's biggest stages
it happens pretty often
oh what a [ __ ] shot by tens one
versus one here jasmine with 14 hp tends
with two
oh my god this move from tens right here
there's no way he expects him
tens what a [ __ ] round bro what was
that
c9 where are you at [ __ ] sinus man
and in july 2018 someone took that
chance
someone who mattered someone who had a
history of going all
in on north american prodigies cloud
nine
i'm tense tyson no
there you go that's it wait last team
last team or have you ever played for a
team
before uh bad news bears but
not really needless to say cloud9 fans
were hyped
especially because tens had just set the
world record on betway's aim map
twice
i don't think that's it that's close not
since stewie2k had such a young
promising and
unproven player been lobbed straight
onto a tier one north american roster
and with the region winning like never
before
people wanted tens to perform being like
fresh blood and like coming into
cloud9 is like without like any
real prior experiences kind of like
crazy
but i'm gonna like put in as much work
as i have to
to be at the top and he did at first
that might be the saving grace for
cloud9 if he's pushing all over the map
there's 10 for the deagle once again
he needs to stay alive he's got to buy
time for his team street's cutting off
the rotation there's another one from 10
can he get the last one it's time he's
won the round of all these deagle shots
the bomb can't be planted and that's a
much needed last round for cloud9 but
despite the initial flashes of
brilliance
it quickly became clear that tens wasn't
cut out for the big leagues
because when the pressure was on he went
from an aim god to
well kind of a bot tens while
he's gonna have to pull off an absolute
miracle if he's going to be able to win
this round an awp
for the youngster already a man crossing
over
my e is stuck in the mud here oboe
looking to lead the way but rush is
there to
cut off the head tens is going to go
down
nothing he can really do a presence
towards b though on a cloud nine on the
get-go and
automatic gets the shot onto marky
intense as well able to chime in and
again for the player we
are hoping to expect more of and
actually we're expecting more we're not
hoping to we do expect more out of him
tens was not living up to expectations
granted he was still inexperienced and
probably could use
a little more time to adjust but he
wasn't just putting up shaky
performances
he was stinking up the server tens had
his shot and
he blew it and here's valens cloud9
former coach
shedding more light on the situation on
ddk's podcast
if you're ted's in a pro team right now
you're having to learn all the things
that it takes to be a pro player
on the fly in the team for the first
time while you're trying to practice
eight ten hours a day at the end of the
day he's 18 or something like that
he knows why he got here or at least he
thinks he knows why he got here
and that's all the stuff that he's
hearing about his mechanical skill and
now he's in a pro team where
he's getting kind of a quick education
on well what does it actually take to be
a pro and stay as a pro
right and those things those two things
are always going to conflict just three
months after joining cloud nine
tens was benched from their active
roster in addition to playing pretty
poorly he also said he had difficulty
synergizing with his teammates
citing what were essentially creative
differences something he got a little
bit of flak for
i was benched because uh just like our
visions
like the way we wanted the team to be
run and the way we
like wanted well me i'm like the only
person
that was like arguing with like people
just because like i was arguing on like
i felt like our style wasn't like good
despite staying on with c9 as a streamer
and content creator
ten's future was unclear some people had
started to view him as a tragic story a
one-dimensional one-trick
an unrealized talent whose incredible
aim was going to waste
they did it at home yeah like yeah the
only thing he does is play that map it's
like
whatever yeah
and then right as it seemed like ten's
competitive hopes had been squashed
forever
this came along project a is our
character-based tactical shooter
it's competitive it has precise gun play
it's set on a beautiful near future
earth
and it has a lethal cast of characters
each with their own unique abilities
whereas some were quick to write off
valorent as a cartoony clone of cs go
tens was among those who saw what it
could be a second chance
another shot for people like him who'd
been left by the wayside in
counter-strike to come back
bigger and better than ever
one enemy remaining
then
from pretty much the moment he first
touched the game ten solidified himself
as one of
if not the most mechanically gifted
valor players in the world
valeric was slower than cs and rewarded
bursty precise gunplay
given what an aimbot tens was it seemed
like the game was made for him
shot my hat stand down
nowhere to run
one enemy remain morning
yikes two done
in april 2019 tens announced that he'd
officially changed games
and became c9's first professional
valorem player i decided to make this
change
because after getting access to the
closed beta i've been having a lot of
fun playing valor lately
and i just thought it would be best if i
changed games
and i'm just really excited for the
future of this game by may he dominated
the latter harder than
anybody in north america becoming the
first person to hit the highest rank in
the game
oh boys let's [ __ ] go
we got valerian finally wait so am i nas
first
yeah and while his roster remains a
little bit lacking in the silverware
department
they've put up stellar performances in
what is undoubtedly valorent's most
competitive region
they they can just play very passively
they have a lot of sound cues to know
that oh
[Music]
the trigger
it's hard to gauge how dominant cloud9
can become ten's problem in cs go was
always performing on stage and
valerian's champions tour is still on
the horizon that said
it's becoming increasingly clear that
tens just might be the single most
mechanically gifted fragger to ever
grace the servers of riot's still
nascent shooter
and he's not even close to hitting his
skill ceiling
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages